what will the french president's second
term look like
emmanuel macron is re-elected but only
after defeating the far right and
gaining votes from people who chose him
reluctantly
how will he deal with a divided
electorate
this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
mohammad jim joom emmanuel macron is
re-elected president of france for a
second term he's the first person in 20
years to achieve the feat but the result
from the second round runoff seems more
a sigh of relief than a grand victory
macron defeated marine le pen who
achieved the strongest ever result for a
far-right candidate
28 of eligible voters didn't cast a
ballot that's the highest abstention
rate since 1969.
macron promised to be a president for
everyone including those who only voted
for him to keep le pen out
attention now turns to the legislative
elections in june both the far right and
far left hope to win more seats and put
pressure on macron's agenda bernard
smith reports from paris
emmanuel macron gambled that a short but
intense election campaign would be
enough
it was his comfortable margin of victory
over marine le pen gives him a second
term at the elysee palace only two
presidents before him have managed that
in his victory speech macron promised
that his next five-year term would be
different
this new era will not be a continuity of
the five previous years but the
collective invention of a revised method
for five better years for our country
and our youth for his supporters this is
a win that endorses what they believe is
their country's role at the heart of the
european union
i'm very happy up to the last minute i
thought i would have fainted you never
know in life anything can happen
today abstentions were significant but
emmanuel macron did a good job in the
first years of his mandate and he
deserves to lead france again
marine le pen gave the far-right their
highest share of the vote in a french
election but her path to the presidency
was blocked again by a republican front
in other words many voters who'd
supported other candidates in the first
round voted this time to keep le pen out
the game is not over in a few weeks
we'll have the legislative elections
which as we know are a distortion of the
political trend and create a risk of
emmanuel macron concentrating all
executive and legislative powers
john luke mellon sean the far left
presidential candidate took just one
percent less of the vote than le pen in
the first round he wants his party franz
unbowed to win enough support in the
legislative elections that macron is
forced to appoint him prime minister
to all of you i say do not resign
yourself on the contrary go candidly and
completely into the action democracy can
once again give us the means to change
direction
the war in ukraine and the rising cost
of living were main concerns for french
voters both issues will likely dominate
the start of macron's second term there
probably won't be much of a grace period
for the president especially from the
left many of whom voted for him
reluctantly macron has promised to raise
the retirement age and make it easier to
hire and fire workers and reform
unemployment benefits protests
asgardia's first term
could erupt again
bernie smith al jazeera paris
all right let's go ahead and bring in
our guests from montoy france thomas
a political scientist
in paris jasin weber program coordinator
at the german marshall fund of the
united states
and in both in the united kingdom
aurelian mondong a senior lecturer in
politics at the university of bath and
author of reactionary democracy how
racism and the populist far-right became
mainstream a warm welcome to you all and
thanks so much for joining us today on
inside story aurelian let me start with
you today there are those who have said
that the result of this election is a
rejection of the far right but marine le
pen achieved the strongest ever result
for a far-right candidate so is it too
early to celebrate
absolutely i don't think there should be
any celebration to be honest marine le
pen has broken a new record uh
for for the far right and for for the
from slash rasam blumen national she has
done much better than her father ever
did she has done much better than she
ever did as well so it's not a victory
by
by any stretch of the imagination and i
think worse than that uh in fact she won
against the candidate he has spent uh
the best of the past five years
mainstreaming a lot of far-right ideas
and particularly pushing a lot of
islamophobic politics into the
mainstream as well so so i think while
it may be an electoral defeat for the
far right the far-right is still winning
ideologically in france at the moment
president macron um had attempted to
appeal to the left especially in the
past few weeks in order to win this
election do you think we're going to see
more attempts from him at a leftward
shift going forward
is he going to pay for example more
attention to social issues going forward
well uh if we if we believe
what he said
during his acceptance speech
well his victory speech yesterday
yesterday evening
he said that he knew he was aware of the
fact that millions of left-wing voters
voted for him only to make sure
far-right would not his power so
under that he would take that into
account
uh while this
while framing a new way to govern okay
but
what we actually do
what it should do
obviously is to try to to create uh what
we call uh
national in french which is basically uh
a specific
global uh political union national unity
government with everyone except far
right and maybe far left so that that's
what he should do in order to to to to
bring political appeasement to the
country
but
we are we have absolutely no evidence
that this is actually what he is going
to do that's what he should do
politically but we don't know if he's
going to do that
jasin
i imagine this must have been a a huge
sigh of relief out of brussels and and
also out of washington with the with the
result of this election correct
yeah exactly i think it was a sigh of
relief in basically all european uh
capitals and of course also on the other
side of the atlantic because um if we
think through the scenario le pen as a
french president that would have been
devastating consequences for the
european union because le pen would have
broken with basically all print or key
principles of european integration such
as the principle of supremacy of eu law
over national law and also kind of the
unwritten principle but the very well
established practice of french german
cooperation on key issues so yes indeed
it is a very good news for europe
but also for transatlantic cooperation
that
macron has won the presidency again and
particularly in brussels
where france is still holding the
rotating presidency of the council of
the eu that means that we can
most likely
um expect more initiatives from the
french side and more also very ambitious
initiatives
from the french side over the next two
and a half months that is the time
remaining of this rotating presidency
and yeah that is a good um step to
advance on many issues of european
integration oh really and i just want to
speak with you for a moment about the
the far right in in france and the
moment that they find themselves in
right now i mean eric zamor had
campaigned on a much more extreme
platform in in the run-up to the first
round of the presidential elections um
did his campaign make marine le pen seem
moderate by comparison and i guess what
i'm asking is
did his campaign normalize marine le pen
absolutely yeah i think in fact uh
marine le pen benefited both from eric
zemo making her look moderate by
comparison as you said because eriksen
was a lot more extreme on various
positions in a way he was espousing old
kind of
uh far right from national positions
which made her look uh more moderate
even though her her program was actually
uh potentially more radical than in 2017
but i think she also benefited
uh from from the continuous
mainstreaming of of far-right politics
in france which we've witnessed in the
past 20 years at least and that macronut
has pushed as well further so at the
same time marine le pen while she did
not run a politically
very good campaign her campaign was her
ordinary uh she benefited from actually
the both both sides uh around her who
one of her one of them making her look
more moderate
and the other one looking at her more
making her look more legitimate and
mainstream so so i think she in a way
was very lucky with the way the um the
campaign panned out she zemo also
allowed her to
avoid some of the flak i think she would
have got regarding russia and her links
to russia uh and it seems that it's
demur who has suffered most from these
tomah let's speak for a moment with you
about what's going on with the left at
this moment in in france um what has
this election cycle meant for the left
jean-luc melanchol he got very very
close to reaching the second round in
the presidential election what happens
now
well um you have to keep in mind that
among the 22 percent
of among french voters who voted for
henrikh mkhitaryan all of them are
left-wing voters and
half of them voted for him because they
agreed with his platform the other half
voted for voted for him only to try to
get a left-wing candidate at the second
round of the election what does it mean
it means that 22 percent is not the
actual uh uh
strength political strength electoral
strength of mr melanie
on this party it is the almost the total
strength of the left wing all combined
in france that's what it means so uh
those who think that there is nothing
else now
on the left side of the political
french spectrum
uh nothing else on the left part than
john mcmillan are in my opinion
misleading
because again
half of his voters in fact are left-wing
voters who would have voted for
something else if it was not if it were
not for the specific rule of the second
round as you know in the presidential
election so
now the question for the left-wing is uh
how to maximize uh the results for the
parliamentary elections obviously the
the logical and the reasonable path
would be a
a complete unity a complete union a
complete left-wing alliance with all
political forces of the
french left-wing the problem is
jean-rickman menosho and his lieutenants
either said no to an allen to an
alliance they said that to the socialist
party which is center left in france uh
or they said yes but with conditions
that were obviously unacceptable
because they they were they were giving
so few to their potential partners
that's what this they made that's what
they have done with the green party so
more or less there will not be uh actual
unity uh for the french parliamentary
elections because jericho is lieutenant
prefer to be
the kings in a lonely lonely situation
instead of trying to build a fair
alliance so it's a pity but you know
it's their strategic choice it's they
are free to do that
jazine so now that emmanuel macron has
been re-elected
there is a huge sense of relief from the
eu but of course there are now
the legislative elections that are
coming up and what i'm curious about is
is there a sense of worry in brussels
about what might happen uh in those
legislative elections uh if macron does
not if his party does not keep its
majority what does that mean for his
championing of the eu going forward
so first of all what we have to bear in
mind in that context is that the french
president has traditionally um a big
margin of maneuver
for his action in terms of foreign
policy because what we call foreign
policy a domain
so a kind of a reserve domain of the
president so even if he doesn't have
the majority in parliament
this would
only have a limited direct impact on
what he can do in europe because he and
his team could still pitch
the ideas and try to
advance things on the level of the
council but also
through the parliament so that would not
be directly affected and also when it
comes to defense
from the first side that would also work
however we have to bear in mind that for
example the french parliament has to
authorize every deployment of the french
armed forces that goes beyond
four months and particularly with view
to a potential deployment of french
forces or a potential new deployment of
french forces to the sahel because you
know that france is now withdrawing from
mali but discussions are already ongoing
how european involvement and also french
involvement in region could look like
that could indeed become
a factor of
concern or of major interest in brussels
and also in other member states and
overall we have to bear in mind that
particularly if macron does not win
the presidential majority the
parliamentary majority
building consensus
with the other parties and having good
relations and working relations with
parliament to get domestic
agenda points implemented will take a
lot of presidential resources and that
are potentially resources that will then
be missing on the european level so
let's see how relations between macro
and parliament will evolve let's see
when whether the french as they used to
do
um
equip him with the parliamentary
majority to govern but i am
currently not very
optimistic that his particular
republican march will have this majority
thomas looked to me like you were
reacting to some of what jazeen was
saying there did you want to jump in
oh
respectfully yes
if we look at the french parliamentary
elections your audience needs to know
that for the past two decades now we
have had parliamentary elections a few
weeks after the presidential election
and here's what happened again and again
and again
um
all
uh electorates all voting blocks if i
may uh
got demobilized you know really really a
drop of the of the voting rate
but
the
voters that voted for the winner of the
presidential election they demobilized
way less than the others
so in terms of actual votes casted
what you see is a landslide in favor of
the guy who won the presidential
election so if things keep being the
same and they have been so for the past
20 years
we will see a landslide majority in
favor of emmanuel macron in the next
parliamentary elections
not because there is an overwhelming
support in his favor but just because of
what we call in french abstention
differential which would be i think in
english
the difference of abstention rate
between the different blocks after the
presidential election
aurelion um marine le pen in her speech
after the results were announced said
that she was going to fight on to secure
a large number of representatives in
these legislative elections does it look
to you like her party could do quite
well in those elections
no i i don't believe so i think i think
thomas summarized the kind of wider
context uh very well and i think it's
it's it's even more difficult for for
the rasam roman national and the far
right in general because they are again
facing a two-round election
uh and generally in the parliamentary
election not only there is more
abstention that tends to benefit of his
differential abstention but tends to
benefit the the party of the of the
newly elected president uh but there
also tends to be more alliances in the
second round against the far right and
and parties uh dropping uh off uh from
uh from the contention um to to make
sure that the far right doesn't go
through and this is why the foreign
national and before national have only
ever had a handful of of seats in
parliament except in 1986 when uh the uh
this curtain was changed to a
proportional vote um so so no i don't
think she will do very well but i think
it will still be interesting to see
actually if she manages to keep her
electorate mobilized uh or whether
actually uh a lot of about electorate
that she got uh this time around may
have been also protest and and and will
turn towards either abstention uh or
towards other parties um so i think i
think there will be lessons to be
learned but i cannot imagine that the
assembler national will do particularly
well in the parliamentary elections and
and aurelia and i i just want to ask you
about something you were kind of
touching on there i mean
the idea of this republican front that
people will join together to to try to
prevent a far-right candidate from
winning the presidency is that something
that's that's been stripped away by by
the result of this election i mean is
that a concept that's sort of crumbling
right now or or is it still strong
it is certainly something that is
crumbling and i think this is something
that has been crumbling for quite a long
time now um the
this republican this republican front is
no longer as strong as it used to be in
2002 for example and you know we've
noticed more and more of the
presidential candidates calling to vote
for le pen we had one in 2017 we had two
this time around
uh i think there's more and more
hesitation as well on the on the right
wing uh of a political spectrum uh with
regard to alliances so i think it will
be again
one of the lessons of this parliamentary
election to see uh what kind of
alliances come out
i suspect there will still be a
semblance of a republican front but but
will be strong enough to prevent before
national from gaining too many mps but
again i think it will be very important
to keep an eye on on actually how
mainstream assemblyman national is
becoming and how weak the republican
front is becoming as well as a result of
the mainstreaming of far-right politics
in france
partly partly because of the actions of
the mainstream itself rather than just
because of the actions of the far right
jasin from your standpoint how much has
the war in ukraine impacted
what went on in this election cycle and
the result of the election
um basically we saw when macro or won
the war in ukraine erupted in um or when
russia invaded ukraine uh in february uh
2022 then we saw that there was kind of
a rally around the flag effect so we saw
popularity scores on intentional vote
for macro
skyrocket but later on it dropped down
and that is basically a classical rally
around the flag effect that we see here
meaning that leaders in times of crisis
or in times of acute crisis
often
are given a bit more credit or have a
bit more popularity among the public
than they would have normally but we saw
that macron's score then dropped down a
little bit or to the almost to almost to
the level that it had before so i
wouldn't say that it has
significantly impacted the campaign
because we have seen that the major
topic in france here is
the coast of living however it had of
course an impact even if that impact was
most likely not as significant as the
debates on the course of living because
we saw for example during the um debate
between the pen and macro that le pen
was really struggling to defend herself
against um the points brought up by
mccall regarding the loan she still has
with the russian bank her
or her
relations with vladimir putin that he
has that she has been
maintaining since quite a few years so
there that definitely has played a role
and when it comes to the question of
capability of french leadership
i assume that that also has played a
role because mccall has already
manifested that he has the capacity to
lead in that kind of coughing so that
might have benefited him but in the end
as i said the dominating topic here was
the cost of living
from your perspective what are some of
the biggest challenges that president
macron will face these next five years
and what do you think his next term is
really going to look like
well
the thing is
what it stands for politically includes
several major reforms on the
social and economic front and by that i
mean reform of our pension system
reform of our
insurance system you know a labor market
insurance system
and also a reform of our health
protection system
the problem is all
free
kinds of reforms the problem is
it would damage the the purchasing power
the living standards of millions and
millions of frenchmen
and as janine already mentioned the cost
of living is already the major priority
the
most important priority
for half of the french population which
means that in fact uh the
the ends already don't meet
for uh half of the french population
nowadays and to to to speak about the
things the way they are you know uh on
the on field uh
the price of bread is rising
the price of fuel is br is rising the
price of in in fact most of the things
you have to buy to feed your family is
rising it's not particularly happening
in france it's in fact all over the
world currently but what we have among
democracies as a reaction to this
situation is obviously
a trend a growing trend of basically
voting against the system and in favor
of the far right if i may i'm sorry for
this dark tone joke
neo-fascism is the new black in terms of
political trends
all right well we have run out of time
so we're going to have to leave the
conversation there thanks so much to all
of our guests thomas guenole jasin weber
and aurelien mandel
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story for me
mohammed jim jerome in the whole team
here in doha bye for now
[Music]